meine reise durch das brett land beginnt
in der hafenstadt kreml im südwesten
englands
die leute hier haben traditionell bei
für die konservativen labour gestimmt
seit dem referendum ist alles anders
60 prozent wollen raus aus der eu haben
die praxis partei stark gemacht hat
können sie seien auch gegen sich selbst
der britisch es rein zu gehen
ja stimmt wir sind hier weil wir wissen
wollen was die leute über der echse
denken ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir
nicht für lief gestimmt hätten das
spaltet die gesellschaft das lässt sich
jetzt sein
ich versuche durch zu kommen öfter du es
tust desto eher gewöhnst du dich an die
kälte kommt
ich bin verabredet mit johnny mercer er
ist abgeordneter der konservativen im
parlament und will das auch bleiben also
muss er kämpfen um jede stimme
früher war immer gegen den br- exit
jetzt ist er dafür auch damit sich das
debakel der europawahl für seine partei
die tories nicht wiederholt was sind
denn gerade die hauptsorgen der wähler
es geht nur um den drechselt daran
kommst du nicht vorbei die leute in
diesem land haben immer daran geglaubt
dass das wofür du abstimmen von den
politikern auch umgesetzt wird so wie
sie es versprochen das thema polarisiert
so viele sagen sie haben für lief
gestimmt und das establishment stoppt
den prozess der für sie oberste
priorität hat
mercer war als soldat drei mal in
afghanistan ist staatssekretär im
verteidigungsministerium seine wähler
versuchte zu überzeugen
wer den br- exit will muss für ihn
stimmen und für seinen premierminister
beust johnson so sagte dass an jeder tür
welche schlüsse ziehen sie aus dem was
gerade passiert ein albtraum oder ich
kann nicht glauben was gerade im
parlament los ist warum kümmert uns das
eigentlich noch was soll denn passieren
heraus so schnell wie möglich wir müssen
raus drei jahre lächerlich und ich habe
da eine ganz klare haltung wir müssen
raus haben sie keine angst war im nu die
praxis überhaupt nicht wir sind ein
gutes land wir möchten nicht von
frankreich oder deutschland beherrscht
werden so wie jetzt wir möchten unsere
unabhängigkeit zurück mercer und sein
team verfolgen eine klare strategie das
thema besetzen mit dem der gegner
erfolgreich war und so die nächste wahl
gewinnen die schon im november sein
könnte im hafenviertel macht die praxis
partei wahlkampf seit zehn monaten gibt
es sie der führer der partei ist nigel
farage hier in krümmel läuft es an
diesem nachmittag nicht so gut
als endlich ein paar leute stehen
bleiben sind es ausgerechnet ihren die
grenzfrage auf und um ihre insel ist
eine der größten streitfragen beim
briggs it was sind die konsequenzen wenn
sie ohne die hier gehen wir sind ihren
die grenze das wollen wir nicht das muss
alles bedacht werden
wir sind in einer zeit groß geworden in
der alles ziemlich friedlich war das ist
positiv eine ganze generation in
nordirland kennt frieden und jetzt
formieren sich all diese gruppen leader
mit dem potenzial für ärger
das wollen wir nicht warum glauben sie
denn war die bread butter also
erfolgreich bei der letzten wahl der
europawahl als modell hat europa wohl
versagt
wir fahren ins tat nur eine halbe stunde
außerhalb von flimm ist hier auf dem
land lebt eine überzeugte europa
gegnerin die für die praxis partei im
europaparlament sitzt jetzt will ein
bitte kommt ins unterhaus lange jahre
saß sie dort für die konservativen
eigentlich das frage ich sie müsste sie
doch zufrieden sein mit der haltung von
boris johnson der den dreck sind unter
allen umständen durchziehen will
in der tat bin ich sehr zufrieden wenn
wir mit einem sauberen schnitt am 31
oktober raus kommen
er sagt ja immer noch dass das möglich
ist auch wenn wir anderen kaum sehen wie
verglichen zur misses may ist er ja ein
geschenk des himmels weil er es
wenigstens versucht aber ich würde kein
geld darauf verwetten dass wir am 31
oktober auch raus sind
sie sprechen immer von einem sauberen
schnitt was sie damit meinen ist doch
ein no de drexhage dir klingt negativ
sauberer schnitt ist viel positiver
viele experten warnen dass der
brechtsche jobs kostet die versorgung
erschwert
warum unterstützen sie etwas das dem
volk schaden könnte weil ich keine
sekunde daran glaube dass der brh exit
uns schaden wird dieselben experten
haben uns gesagt dass wenn wir für lief
stimmen am nächsten tag das armageddon
über unsere wirtschaft hereinbrechen
würde dass wir sofort eine halbe million
jobs verlieren würden
das wäre ein neues sparpaket bräuchten
dass es chaos geben würde
passiert ist genau das gegenteil die
arbeitslosigkeit ist so niedrig wie nie
gibt so viele jobs wie nie wir brauchen
nicht auf diese angstmacher zu hören
in cambridge treffe ich den historiker
christopher clark seit langem lebt und
lehrt er hier und beobachtet die
entwicklung im land mit großer sorge von
haustür zu haustür sind wir gegangen und
der sagte ja ganz egal ob die experten
jetzt vor einem no deal warnen und sagen
das hätte schlimme folgen das volk hat
ebenso abgestimmt und deshalb müssen wir
das jetzt durchziehen viel wie
gefährlich halten sie seine einsatz also
ich finde diese einschätzung extrem
gefährlich für sie sagen weil damit wird
ein verfassungs dualismus hergestellt
nicht zwischen zwei verschiedenen arten
die demokratie und das darf nicht
geschehen
das ist einfach so nach einem votum wir
sozusagen in das ungewisse eines no deal
austritts springen das ist meines
erachtens eine eine
verantwortungslosigkeit sondergleichen
aber es gibt diese rhetorik zwischen dem
volk und dem establishment das ist
natürlich eine sehr gefährliche sprache
eine sehr gefährliche rhetorik und ich
halte diejenigen die diese sprache in
der öffentlichkeit benutzen und
inklusive die die führung des jetzigen
kabinetts für mitschuldig an eine
unterminierung der demokratischen kultur
in diesem land
und wie hat das brett referendum
überhaupt die politik und die
gesellschaft in großbritannien verändert
es hat einen geist des streites des der
polarisierung in die in das land
gebracht in die politische kultur des
landes die die meines erachtens also
nicht die vorhin nicht da war aber der
wegfall von zivilität und von
höflichkeit der die enthemmung der
sprache die rhetorische enthemmung diese
tendenz jetzt in den kategorien freund
und feind zu denken das ist etwas neues
in der britischen
politischen kultur würde sagen eine der
wiegen der politischen kultur ist oxford
hier ist großbritannien liberal und
international viele studenten aus der
ganzen welt kommen hierher
zugleich ist oxford aber auch eine der
kaderschmieden der politischen elite die
großbritannien in den exit geführt hat
wir treffen leo mädchen erst 21 und
kommt aus schleswig holstein hier am
jesus college studierte politik
philosophie und wirtschaft
ich habe mich 2015 beworben und wurde
dann im frühjahr 2016 angenommen das
heißt vor dem referendum
und auch in den ersten gesprächen hier
aber noch ganz unklar und das jetzt
passiert oder nicht und ich hatte noch
gefragt ja was passiert mit mir kann ich
hier ohne weiteres studieren was
passiert mit den gebühren und da wurde
gesagt machen sie sich keine gedanken
das wird nicht passieren
leo nimmt uns mit in dem pub der german
club trifft sich sie alle hier fühlen
eine gewisse unsicherheit wie es
weitergehen soll
hallo uni in großbritannien allgemein
nicht nur deutsche sind an diesem abend
da sondern auch briten franzosen polen
italiener
wenn dann machen wir uns darüber sorgen
wie wir zum beispiel wieder nach hause
kommen ob flüge gestrichen werden oder
züge gestrichen werden zum beispiel oder
ob wir vorher großeinkauf machen mussten
müssen vor dem 31
oktober er solche sachen
manchmal wundern sie sich aber auch wie
unpolitisch viele ihrer kommilitonen im
oxford sind fällt mir mega auf als das
ist dieses einfach die studenten keinen
bock mehr drauf haben und ich glaube man
also ich als deutscher bin überrascht
wie wenig dann auch die studenten sagt
also sozusagen selber irgendwie anpacken
um diese situation zu verändern praxis
verpassen
für mich persönlich ist es eine tragödie
ich habe meine heimat mit 18 verlassen
behüte sweater und gutes essen zurück
gelassen weil ich hier eine zukunft für
mich sagt es macht mich traurig dass das
jetzt alles infrage gestellt
unsere demokratie ist nicht einzigartig
sie ist alt und die institutionen sind
fest verankert vieles beruht auf
vertrauen und tradition
das wird täglich mit füßen getreten mir
macht sorgen was noch passieren wird
zurück in flims die nächsten tage
könnten in sachen dragset entscheiden
sein
wieder einmal und trotzdem erlebe ich
die menschen hier überraschend gelassen
[Musik]
muss jetzt einfach sein und schon so
einen weiten weg gegangen
wir können nicht zurück uns wurde gesagt
bereitet euch auf den exit vor was
sollen wir uns denn vorbereiten das weiß
doch keiner john cleese der komiker
würde es wahrscheinlich so auf den punkt
bringen kopf in die hand und dann auf
den tisch schlagen
[Musik]
britischer humor vielleicht lässt sich
das brechtsche drama auch nur so
ertragen
[Musik]
auf meiner reise bin ich immer wieder
der überzeugung begegnet drei jahre und
nur ein einziges thema irgendwann muss
auch mal schluss sein
[Musik]